moins dépendre de la russie pour ses
énergies le sujet fait consensus parmi
les 27 depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine les prix du gaz ou de
l'électricité flambe pour faire baisser
la facture et gagner en indépendance
énergétique la commission européenne
envisage des achats groupés de gaz
d'hydrogène et de pétrole à l'image de
ce qu'elle a pu faire pendant la
pandémie en passant des commandes
commune de vaccins anti copie de 19 la
mesure est notamment soutenue par la
france et l'espagne
la garantie de l'approvisionnement
énergétique et l'évolution du prix du
gaz et de l'électricité
il s'agit de deux éléments pour lesquels
je pense que la commission européenne
peut
trouver une réponse équilibrée qui
permettra à tous les pays de pouvoir
répondre en fonction de la gravité de la
situation sur cet aspect nous et notre
aspectos en attendant d'acheter
peut-être davantage de pétrole algérien
ou de gaz norvégien bruxelles veut
négocier sans attendre avec les états
unis la présidente de la commission veut
profiter de l'arrivée du président
américain en europe
je vais discuter avec le président
gbagbo doit arriver à privilégier les
livraisons de gaz naturel liquide
américains vers le nord européenne dans
les prochains nous visons des livraisons
supplémentaires sont les yeux prochain
hiver d'un axe tout winch est
aujourd'hui la russie fournit 40% du gaz
importé par l'ue eux et 46% du charbon
la commission européenne prévient
quelles que soient les politiques
décidées à l'issue du prochain sommet
européen il faudra du temps pour se
défaire de cette dépendance elle ajoute
la solution devra aussi venir de
l'augmentation de la part des énergies
renouvelables